this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you all for coming in person
um
and yeah so today I'm going to talk
mainly about long-ring coding rnas or or
various subcategories
okay so so most of us are familiar with
the central plasma
um we know that you we get some kind of
a signal or a cue from the environment
which elicits some kind of change in the
DNA which produces an RNA a
transcription produces an RNA and then
translation translates that are immune
so protein which uh for most of us for
many years this protein with what we
assumed was contributing to the response
but in the past uh I'd say 20 30 years
we know a lot more about the non-coding
finding portions of the transmission
film completely Long Way cutting rnas
and small non-cutting rnas and indeed
the there are other things that can help
regulate responses including uh
post-transcriptional learning
modification that all are added to these
different classes of rnas that all
contribute to regulating
response to changes in the environment s
for this poor little arabidopsis plan
now the lab is is broadly interested in
all things RNA but in general are or
more specifically we're interested in
Long incoming rnas posture
entrepreneuriality modifications I
alluded to here with the owner lollipops
changes in RNA abundance or stability
and how that just changes in
transcriptional regimes help plants
respond to stress or respond changes and
then of course RNA compartmentalization
within the cell so here I'm talking
about stress
and we work in a variety of systems the
good thing about most bioinformatics is
that you can do it some number of
systems you have to be working with
experts who know something about the
plants that you're working with but in
general our home based so to speak is
okay so today long encoding rnas now
what are Longman coding rnas um
obviously they're non-coding but Andrew
long so greater than cumulative
nucleotides in general they don't have
an open reading praying for any 200 or
sorry even 100 immune acids but we heard
from uh last week from poly but there
are a whole bunch of transcripts in the
cell that encode or have short of the
reading frame I mean in fact that would
be a subject of a few of my slides later
on but in General Lee rnas are long no
open reading frame they generally they
can come from anywhere in the genome we
kind of categorize them based on where
they are coming from genome most are
Paul 2 transcribes and it's typically a
display for sequence operation
in terms of function leak RNA is
primarily function inside the nucleus
the most perhaps the most famous long
encoding RNA generally is isn't even
thought of as a link RNA even so famous
it's the polymerase our name and the
telomerase RNA functions the nucleus to
maintain chromosome ends it's
functionally conserved across all
eukaryotes it's missing in the model and
consumer software but it's present in
almost every single one unit every
single species so it's a highly
consumption concerns
long including RNA
there are also other link rnas that
function to modulate chromatin Dynamics
this can be compaction or opening up a
chromatin a famous example in plants is
the Apollo and Garnet that forms these
chromatin Loops that help to suppress or
to regulate pinoid uh a conscription and
actually modulates how Roots root
branching occurs
perhaps maybe even more famous
incarnates and actually anti-centric RNA
called cooler that regulates uh uh the
FLC Locus and modulates flowering and
brassicasey and these cool air that
represents a
[Music]
okay back to Lee County's in the nucleus
so uh cool air as I mentioned represents
it's possibly incarnate the modulates uh
epigenetic States so we're talking about
histone or DNA methylation and then
there's another highly conserved leak
RNA called pig1 which actually binds to
transcription factor and targets
transcription factors to implications
I'm gonna come back to hit one and
tomorrow in a moment and then of course
we have other uh link rnas perform other
functions inside the nucleus all of this
is to regulate either transitional
Dynamics or to modulate a half-life of
maturity of messenger elements with
again the sole reception
out in the cytoplasm there are fewer
characterized functions for cytopathic
rnas but the perhaps the first link RNA
identified in Plants e940 I've been
abide in soybean are medical and soybean
it's actually uh binds to protein in the
cytoplasm and can be the cell that cell
mobile so for example of global zinc
Gardens and then of course there's
another link RNA in the cytoplasm
another example of
kind of the cytoplasm that actually
sequesters micro rnas and decoys and
pulls them away from your energy Target
so this long list of of functional
archetypes
um represents the best of what we know
about planting rnas
um but also represents most of what we
know about
aside from this list there's maybe five
or six other well-characterized link
rnas they fall Within These functional
archetypes the list of characterized
link rnas and rabidopsis is about 2825
so I would argue that the extents of
what we know the extent to which link
Carnegie contributes to critical
relevant processes is poorly understood
largely because we don't even know
what's there we haven't known what's
actually transcribed with present in the
genome so here I'm showing you a biology
of some of our favorites plant species
and by favorites I mean these are the
ones that we we study and we are most
deeply sequent
and then of course there's a few uh
basil uh eukaryotes here at the bottom
um and in terms of link rnas that are
present that are available and annotated
in the genome species of course the
rabidopsis has the most but it's nothing
in comparison to human's device I mean
this is largely due to the human Mouse
on code projects which went through and
attempted to annotate all functional
elements of those two genomes
in contrast where lincolnates have been
identified in Plants we have different
criteria and experimental evidence used
in that identification efforts and so
now we start to be comparing apples of
Origins when we're looking at rice or
rabidopsis and kinase so we're not even
making a pair of comparisons when we
want to start looking
um
performing function
Now link rnas can be identified from our
sequencing data M and when we look at
the amount of available
sequencing data as of 2018 it starts to
become become more
equivalents between plants
at some points you have a wealth
providing sequencing data you don't
really need even more and you can start
identifying longer cutting rnas from all
of this data and so really that's what
we decided to do we've decided to go
through and start typing find A's using
the same method the same criteria and we
started this in the basket case
now we went through and we processed
probably way too much
20 terabytes or 20 terabases of RNA
sequencing data which if you know
anything about sequencing data that's a
metric
load
um most of it is from a robot offsets
but we had a good amount from from
Brassica rapper we processed all of this
simple thing data we remapped everything
identified transcripts using this
information and then figure out which of
those transcripts look like
for all four of these species we
identified uh thousands tens of
thousands of incarnas about 20 000 than
rabidopsis and More in each of the other
uh for these interests and then we
performed basic characterization and
putative functions
and so just uh some general take homes
from the general identification is that
we used short read data we used long
read data some of our own Longview data
and to identify with kinase and then we
this process kind of helped us we went
into this a little bit naive and
thinking that it wouldn't maybe be very
straightforward and super easy but we
developed additional metrics that we
believe will help us
so throughout this square is
transcriptional artifacts in future
identification
but let's talk about what we've done for
Arabic offices and the other brassic
cases we've really gone from a scenario
like this where okay we've got a lot of
protein coding genes about 24 000 or so
we have some small rnas and we have some
link rnas and we have some functional
characterized environs and then we've
gone through a scenario more like this
where all of a sudden everything's
transcribed uh who cares like what does
this even mean how do we make sense of
this
um and so now we have the the what I
call the fall Summit dibling Garden
application where we've been doing a lot
of work we've been going up this this
mighty mighty mountain and we reach a
peak and then we realize that we have a
whole lot left to do because now we're
going from identification so now we
really need to start making uh we need
to transition from identifying
transcripts to figuring out what those
transcript is
so we can make some of those inferences
based on the analyzes and the the work
that Kyle and Leon and Kailyn and others
did in the lab
um and one of those uh
one of the things that we can use to
help us is to Simply determine like
which of these loci which of these
Guardians are concerned
and I mentioned that the telomerase RNA
is highly concerned it's both sequence
conserved within families and it's both
and it's structurally conserved you can
use multiple sequence alignments to
infer link rnas or sorry plumbers rnas
and other families across the land plant
language so they're actually pretty easy
to identify what's you know what you're
looking for and in addition the head one
Locus the head one link RNA is also
buried across uh
right so the question is are there other
telomerase rnas are there other hid ones
are there other highly concernedes and
what I'm showing here is is again
phylogeny of brass Casey along with uh
taranaya hassanana so a representative
of the sister uh family clay Macy and
simply asking at the sequence and
Symphony level do we see conservation of
any of our 20 000 direct bosses
very very straightforward sequence and
sympathy and we see that for sure uh we
see that for about 250 of these 20 000
incarnas we see that there is sequence
conservation that we can detect and
these are coming from satanic loci
these link rnas are probably
um doing something important they're
concerned across a very long distance
much more so than the bulk of the about
bounces and Grains about 43 percent of
the around
autism Guardians are species specific so
this is a big contrast to where we're
sitting here and if we go and we
generate sequence alignments and we look
at uh
structural data from
individual structural data then we can
actually infer and we can determine that
some of these link rnas are actually
conserved outside of raster Casey and
impact in much of people in Asia's such
as headline what is
so these are obviously if you're cherry
picking your data and you want to are
cherry picking your candidates for
functional analysis these are a strong
place to start
and for example as an example uh so uh
this is a collaboration with uh the
Bible science and Gregory Labs we
identified a link RNA that was conserved
Crossing Casey it was actually
originally named cobra
um it's covering up a cute name so link
Cobra so conserved in Brassica
but this
about 450 nucleotides and you'll see
from this alignment that there are two
regions of a strong sequence similarity
and these two regions correspond to snow
rna-like motifs so they're not full
samrnas that they share sequence
similarity and in addition these are
protein binding sites that Gregory lab
identified through hep C
so we have some information straight off
one it's circling RNA and it's protein
binding
or it's bound by voice which isn't
surprising because all RNA
um
okay so uh
the Boston lab and the Gregory lab
Marianna and Kyle both created different
tdna or crispr immunogenesis lines here
we're showing both of these and you see
that they're not only delayed growth but
there's also decreased in Sea
germination after 48 hours so these
mutants for this long including RNA are
having an impact on
element
and going back to the the protein
binding aspects performing chirp and
mess we see that this
RNA so chirp and mess is essentially
you're pulling out the RNA from
amiibo and then you're performing mass
spec on anything any proteins that are
bound for that RNA you see that there's
a whole set there's something like 70 or
so proteins that are bound and most of
these are either they're transcription
factors or other RNA binders
now the reason that we initially or the
reason that
we went with this link RNA and looking
at
um its protein capacity rather than
whether or not it was a CIS or trans
regulator that's because this uh from
all the transfer filming data that we
had we can tell that the expression in
this link RNA wasn't correlated with the
expression of the h astings so we
thought that its function was most
likely through whatever proteins I was
acting with and not through some kind of
CIS or trans Revolution
now getting back at those CIS or trans
Regulators we know for at least a subset
of them that those link rnas should
likely interact with the rddm pathway or
other
modifiers and epigenetic states are
chromatin multipliers and so there's a
whole lot of data about available for
small rnas mapping back to so there's a
whole bunch of small RNA data as well as
small RNA data produced from mutants
within the Arduino pathway and so we can
test whether any of our link rnas look
like either well if they look like
Apollo or they look like where any type
of leak on you that would regulates
confidence
and so first we we simply took a small
rnas from a database at the Myers lab
curates and we asked if those small rnas
overlap with any of our loot contents
we see that about in this upset thought
we see that about 4 000 of our arriving
office attorneys overlap with small rnas
and of those about two thousands in the
tissues for which we had data 2000 of
those
link rnas had a dynamic relationship
with small rnas
and find that they're neither being
regulated by or are helping production
uh
now the rdd and path rddm Pathways is
traditionally thought of as regularly
translatable elements and so the next
question would be whether any of these
link rnas are actually those
transposable elements in Disguise and so
we went through and we re-annotated all
the transposable element we re-annotated
The arabidopsis genome for transposable
elements and then we asked if any of
those transposable elements overlapped
our link rnas
um so to consider overlap it would be 50
for more the tee overlap people with RNA
so about a thousand of the original 20
000 derivative kindness overlap
to some extents with the transposal
element but of those so now these are
called te Associated link earnings of
those only 170 of these four thousands
are te associated with kineas suggesting
that these link rnas a large number of
these are acting more like Apollo
they're active modifiers and chromatin
Dynamics rather than being actively
suppressed by the RDU map
we can also get Oris that's whether or
not our link rnas are
being activated in response to changes
in the environment so are they stress
sensors or are they developmental
centers and here I'm just showing you
stress data this is
um
essentially asking if any of our link
rnas are differentially expressed in
response to any of these five stresses
and you see that there's a decent number
there's actually not as many as we
initially thoughts but there's about a
thousand or so incarnates that are
differentially expressed in response to
one of these five stresses and we know
that a subset of these are Ada of
dependents so we can further narrow down
the regulatory pathway
for these link armies
and so if a link RNA is stress
responsive that doesn't necessarily mean
itself there are a lot of genes that
gets activated or repressed during heat
stress for instance you know it's every
paper you read it's going to be three or
four or five thousand genes or
differentially expressed so to ask
whether or not these link rnas are
actively regulating the
acting assists or Regulators we
look to see if
their expression is is changing that the
correlation in their expression with
adjacent Gene be changing the
responsibility
so here I'm just showing you a very
simple cartoon of a long non-coding RNA
and it's surrounding genes Gene X and
Gene Y and we'd imagine a scenario where
when the leak RNA is upregulated
actively is suppressing the adjacent
Gene Gene X and so you see it decreases
an expression now we would expect that
correlation so this would show up as a
negative correlation expression
found a tissue where the lead Guardian
was upregulated but we would also expect
to see scenarios that this was a
specific correlation we would expect to
see scenarios where the correlation
changes the Dynamics change
so we went through and we asked how many
uh these link rnas these stress
responsively garnas were correlated with
their adjacent protein coding genes
adjacent genes and then of those how
many of those either
positive or negative Regulators how many
of those correlations change and then
it's the the change that we're
interested
the specific form of
America so again a large number uh I
think it's uh again about 1500 or 2000
Lee rnas are probably acting as CIS
regulators and we can further look into
those using
um either transcription or epigenetics
to the
get a better understanding of that
relationship
we can also look at the correlation or
the similarities in expression and
develop these large
co-expression Networks like I'm showing
here where this network is actually
showing a representing a whole bunch of
transcripts that are similarly expressed
so they fall into the same module of
transcripts and in this case the
unifying feature unifying pattern for
all of these transcripts is really this
peak early on in wounding and so these
genes would be what we would consider
wounding responsive and in fact they
would probably I would call them
responsive like they would be early
and if you look at the clusters of genes
that are interacting particularly
transcription factors that are involved
it all makes sense with something that
would be responding to the jasminic acid
responsive uh genes and you'll also have
wounding responsive genes again all
thanks to the massive amount
ification that's already present for
around
us and so we can use all of this
information to say okay we have five leg
rnas in this module what are they
connected with who whom are they
interacting with
and can we infer can we make a
functional hypothesis based on those
interactions
and because we have we're in a rapid
offices and we have a whole bunch of Def
seek data and other chip c data for the
transcription factors we can make
assumptions or hypotheses about which
specific transcription Factor that's
actually regulating these
are during the release
so normally this would just be a kind of
expression network but when you can
overlay aspects such as transcription
Factor binding then all of a sudden you
can start to call this a writing
so again about 2 000 link rnas interact
with mrnas in a stress or development
associated
so I've just told you three or four
different scenarios different types of
data we can use to make functional
hypotheses about our link rnas but
that's still it doesn't doesn't get you
to the function of just the hypothesis
so we have all this evidence to support
function we have interesting features or
Associated modules that we would like to
to test
so now we need to start doing some
rigorous genetics
um so again arabidopsis is useful
there's a lot of insertion lines
available crispr is very easy in
arabidopsis so we can do this and we can
combine it with
High cup of phenotype or a very simple
very rapid screens such as germination
screens so then
succeed at functionally annotating
our laundry cutting line
but let's go through a couple of
examples where we
or we're beginning to do just that so
here we're we're looking at
um we're using the germination screen
this is work done by Kalin
um and we're simply asking link rnas
that are expressed and fit into this
module of germination Associated
transcripts are they if we mutate them
are they associated with a germination
delay or germination phenotype
and it's not I am not a germination
expert by any means but this is just an
easy and Rapid phenotype to go after we
want to validate our approach and we're
doing this with uh lee rnas with the
phenotypes it's easy
and easy to score is simply this we see
very little germination or delay
germination or the leak RNA mutants
where we see uh germination is just fine
for the wild type
and so uh Kalin screened through 11 or
sorry 14 different so incarnas that fit
into this module of
germination Associated transcripts and
we see a decrease in germination rates
for 11 of those now as you see the the
germination decrease varies quite a bit
wild type
maybe a lot of pipes not even shown I
think wild types here
um
yeah
um but as you can see there's there's
quite quite a range but there are some
that have very strong decreases
so then Kalyn had part of her
distribution work has been to go through
and and assess what is actually
occurring at where what some of those
long in the 29 days so these lgd1 or
lgds
um
this one sorry lgd1 so we believe it's a
CIS regulator of path2 and the reason
that we think that that's occurring
um is
partly shown in the schematic here where
we have lgd1 is is this box here uh
there's a pseudo Gene uh just directly
Downstream of lgb1 going in the opposite
direction and then there's this cooking
um
cooking coding Gene called path2 so Pap
is a phosphatic acid phosphase it's
important for a germination it's
important to live with us
now we had two Independents TDA
insertion lines that disrupted
um lgd1 oh and I should uh also mention
that both lgd1 and path2 show expression
High expression and um germinating seeds
and early seeds
however the pseudogene does not
and so uh just to remind you again in
the phenotype
um
both of these alleles we see decrease in
germination so slower germination
um and then once the seeds do germinates
they typically or sorry there's reduced
germination and then for the seasons
that do germinate there's uh they're
they're germinated much similar ways and
then some of those seedlings actually
essentially have boards and die
now
some other things I've marked here on
the schematic is that lgd1 overlaps two
enhancer regions and one of these
enhancer regions contains a MIB 107
transcription Factor binding site now
MIB 107 is interesting because MIB 107
regulates other genes associated with
germination in fact nib 107 is critical
for proper C code
or it regulates genes in it yeah
important for privacy care formation so
the fact that MIB 107 is here
and not disrupted by the two Salk gdma
insertions that you have here but it is
found within the transcribed region of
lgb1 is highly reminiscent of the Apollo
story where Apollo actually forms this
permit the move and helps to regulate
the expression of the Gene but when you
disrupt Apollo you disrupt the
expression of the down through Gene
Henry so this is the hypothesis we're
working with
um but obviously Kaelyn has quite a bit
more likely
questions now the last story that I
uh vignette that I want to tell you
about is about some of these link rnas
that actually contain short of
ingredients
now a link RNA the short open reading
frame is probably not a regarding right
um so we don't necessarily know that
these short open reading frames are
producing peptides we have evidence to
suggest that but we don't know that the
peptide is the function of units is what
I'm trying to say so Enon 40 this this
incarnado is characterized by Martin
Crosby in the late 80s also has two
shorter but the functional units I mean
I'm 40 and the learning itself not those
two groups so we have a whole bunch of
link rnas I think there's something like
150 uh link rnas will be identified that
have these open reading frames within
them and here we're just characterizing
what the link earnings look like or
sorry what the open reading frames look
like what kinds of proteins will they
produce
and here this is just for the paper we
were just describing that there were
more found within the airport the older
annotation or fewer of these found
within our annotation that's not as
important what's really critical here is
that you can see there's a lot of really
short
um
potential peptides that are being
produced for which we have evidence from
a privacy data so this is actually in
collaboration is here and for some of
these we also have evidence
spectator
so each of these open reading frames or
sorry each of these peptides produced
from a short open reading plane we then
asked are these just fragments are these
fragments of known proteins or are they
something novel right now novel what
happens
and be probably hard to see but the
green circles which there aren't very
many of them those are the peptides that
actually corresponds to a node there's
only 10 for you in the back very few of
these peptides that are actually look
like an end protein some of them have
already been annotated or looked like
hypothetical proteins
um so that's another 0.7 but
hypothetical protein again in a rapid
opposite doesn't mean anything it just
means maybe we have mass effect we don't
but then most of these peptides are
unique there's no similarity to them in
any other
protein database and any other you can
again it doesn't necessarily mean
anything but it is interesting what what
might be
doing and so we went through and we
decided let's take the link rnas the
campaign short open reading frames that
are concerns highly consultant and let's
see if we can test uh come up with some
way a genetic and a molecular way of
testing for function
so first again the standard germination
essay for one of these uh peptides one
of these
um supposed to be peptide with
germination feedback pgd
um one of these it's expressed early on
in seeds or in seedlings and seedling
roots and so this was the one that
Alyssa tested on place to see if it
interfered with germination
and
um it did so over a period of four days
um most or all of the Columbia the wild
type seeds germinated but there was
significant delay
insertion line for this particular
this particular source
so okay that's that's for the link RNA
the peptide that's uh found where we
would expect HIV sheet effect but what
about these others where they're not
necessarily expressed in ceilings or in
German seeds so like what the phenot
factor we would look for with them and
so with this we collaborated with Magda
to use the pheno rigs to figure out if
there's any kind of growth delay for
these particulars
and so we grew each of these mutants
into the phener rig we took images every
30 minutes
um took that over a period of three
weeks you see the plant s slowly growing
and then
when using plant CV we go through and
figure out what the growth rates are for
the
compare it to Wild type of course all in
like randomized screening randomized
plot designs
and what we see so so this was a work by
Alyssa and an Ru student over the summer
is that these mutants do display these
mutants display differences in growth
rates so we have a couple of two mutants
that show decreases in growth rates and
then interestingly we have one view that
actually shows an increase
okay so now uh what I'm not showing you
is all the uh the peptide containing new
garnas that don't have female names
so now we have some interesting
candidates we have a reason we're using
this hyper screen to figure out which of
these uh peptides or these sword
containing returnings might be of
interest and then we need some kind of
additional hiker puts way of figuring
out
where we go what we target
function work develop Ed stage with
stress Etc
so in collaboration with Ola we're using
a
protocol called lip Ms limited
proteolysis Mass Spec and how this works
is you take protein extracts from your
tissue of Interest wherever you think
that your peptide is expressed you
extracts or take that protein extract
and you mix it with a synthesized
peptide so we went to gen script and we
asked genescript and synthesize the
peptides for I think 10 or 11 of the the
peptides that we're interested in we mix
it
with the extract and what happens what
potentially we hope is happening is that
our peptide will interact with a protein
or a set of proteins and will change the
conformation of those proteins
then we perform limited proteolysis we
get different size of peptides as a
result from that proteolysis and what we
hope is that the addition of the peptide
is going to change the pattern of
proteolysis meaning that that peptide is
actually interacted with one or more
proteins in this extract
and so what this would look like is if
you're it's almost like a volcano plot
from potential Comics you would expect
to see some kind of increase significant
increase in the number of peptides that
are changing or moving
um uh I say moving that are difference
between your control and your your
peptide
setting
so let's just show you the the peptide
that Alyssa's looked at so far so at1
g06113 produces a very short peptide so
the 27 nucleotide Bond
open reading frame except the nine amino
acid peptide
highly conserved in fact it's concerned
across all brassicasey and the the
nucleotide sorry the amino acid sequence
is completely concerned across all grass
caves oh another important things is
that we know that this transcript the
transcript itself is responsive to
oxidative stress as well um
also is differentially expressed during
hypoxia
so we have some expectations about what
this protein might
so when Alyssa added this peptide to
extracts
she saw that there were 23 peptides from
18 proteins that were differentially
abundant uh between Mock and peptide
tree examples
we then can go through and just sanity
check and make sure that the targets are
actually representing proteins coming
from transcripts that are expressed in
the same tissues
but not present in the same tissue then
they can't be interacting
and we see that so here on top is the
our peptide sorry the transcript of
encoding for our peptide and then you
see that most of these fat proteins are
sorry the transcripts encoding for all
the interacting proteins also expressed
uh in the same position
and if you look at the you perform a
simple go enrichment of the proteins
present here we see that there's
enrichment of
oxidore reduct-based activities while
molecule binding but more importantly
responsive stress abiotic stimulus the
chemical chemical stress so things that
that almost look like what we're seeing
with the transcript itself
okay
so with that some final take homes
we've identified a lot of them Guardians
we identified lincolnism for absolutely
critical uh species within the mustard
lineage
um and we are in the process of
functioning characterized and really
screening through and figuring out which
of the rnas we think are
low-hanging fruits to perform functional
balance is
and then we're also moving our
annotation efforts to other species so
there's a lot of link rnas that have
been in a lot of species for which
incarnates have been poorly annotated
and we want to fix that
um
and yes so with that thanks to a lot of
people in the lab
and shut down the newest member in the
lab is going to be continuing on with
the Lee Carney story working on a
project that hopefully will Encompass
both plants and mammals large
collaborative project and that's
something to thank Mark balstein who's
in the in the room as well as other
collaborators Brian Gregory Eric clients
Paulie Rebecca Murphy and some Ru
students and then of course the other
heads of the Cerberus here at Sky Ola
and Naga and then all the people here
who actually contributed to going to
research itself and with that take any
questions
you showed us that the expression of
quite a large number of them were
affected by instructors yes
we have the 12th number was really quite
small
yes so the
um
it's all about sampling
um so so really it's uh you're right
that there are like Heats and cold and
drought there are osmotic stresses and
we should see quite a bit of overlap
um
we do see let me go back to that
yeah so this is what you're referring to
um and the fact that there's very little
overlap between the
um this set here which you would imagine
would reflects all of the osmotic
stresses
um
I think in part that represents the
specificity of Lee Garners
I think that's that's the general
the response that I would give for that
um
yeah
um
of
certainly responsive
stresses of an epidemic modeling of the
genome is something that
is
we started looking at the intersection
of ethnic smart and when you
confirmative
are gone
yeah so so we haven't looked at specific
cases we have we have
um kind of a global or we performed a
global survey of the transcriptome and
separating
um you know protein coding genes from
kinase physical development
um but you're right it would be really
um
it would be advantageous for us to go
through and figure out for the ones that
are uh particularly like stress
responsive is what's initiating that
transcriptional activation
um and I think it's for us it's just
about finding the right paired
experiments
um so the other thing here to answer to
go back to your question is that the
heat cold and salt are coming from the
same experiment or the same
there's a little bit of batch effects
involved in what's going on here so this
the drought and the lights are
performing different people and there
may be
let's go to your your question you're
absolutely right we need to find the
rights paired experiments where they
perform the epigenetic
analysis at the same time as the stress
and that's there it's just bandwidth
anyway
so what do we know about this all right
I'll put a flowering pants
um does uh does Cisco count
I I say like you know from
the mountain the the Lincoln that I said
was conserved across land plants so hid
one is present
um in in Fisco we know that you can take
the actually you know they didn't do
that
um we know very little so I think it's
the is
so there's a couple of examples of
deeply conserved Lee garnets the
telomerase RNA has been identified in
all of chlorophytic organisms and been
functionally validated in a few
but other than that it's I think one
group has identified just on a
characterization of blue turnings in
Cisco but again that's that's that's it
for Outsider future experience
ciliates is where the polymers first
identified so
it doesn't quite count
okay thanks very much
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu